[NO AUDIO]
CATHY L. DRENNAN: So
welcome everybody.
I hope you're really excited
about this semester coming
up, and getting
involved with teaching.
So I am Professor Cathy
Drennan, a professor
here at MIT in the Chemistry
and Biology Department.
And I want to start today--
so this workshop is about
stereotype, stereotype threat,
wise criticism,
unconscious bias.
And I want to start, because
you're going to be teachers,
with telling you
about my motivation
for doing this training.
I think she's a chemist.
Why is she standing up
here telling us about this?
So as teachers, it's good
to tell your students
about your motivation.
So what is my motivation?
Well, my motivation was-- this
a story from a number of years
ago, and I was asked to
attend a workshop happening
at Harvard on increasing
diversity in the sciences.
And so when you went to
register for this workshop
they gave you a
homework assignment.
I thought that was interesting.
So my homework assignment was to
go to the chemistry department
and interview all the
undergraduates that
were members of underrepresented
minority groups.
And I discovered at the time,
this was a number of years ago,
there were two, and
both of these students
had transferred very recently
to other departments.
So that was not the
best indication,
but the students were very
interested in talking to me.
And I said, I want to hear
about your experience.
I want to think about what the
department could do better.
Again, this is an
issue from the past.
Things are a lot
better right now.
So I met with these students,
and one in particular
was just really engaged with me.
They're like, yes, I want
to help you figure out
what's going on, and talking
about their experience,
and thought a lot about what
could have been different.
And finally, came
up with this thing,
and he said, I never had
a TA that believed in me.
And I just thought--
I was not expecting
that response.
Because I'd been
working with TAs at that
point for quite some time.
And the TAs were
really wonderful.
They were engaged and excited.
And I just thought,
somehow the TAs--
there had been this disconnect.
And I said, well, what
did the TAs say to you?
What happened?
And he thought
about it and tried
to come up with an
example, and then realized,
it wasn't what they said,
it was what they didn't say.
And that just stuck with me.
And I thought, his TAs
probably had no idea
that he was feeling this way.
Here was this kid sitting
in the classroom thinking,
no one believes that
I can do chemistry,
and no one else was thinking
that but him, probably.
So I said, we need
to talk about this.
We need to talk
about how we can all
have classrooms where everyone
can reach their full potential.
So that's what this
training is about today.
We're going to start
this discussion, how
do we create classrooms
where everyone can reach
their full potential, where no
one's worried, sitting in there
really worried,
about what someone
might be thinking about them.
So again, as a teacher, what
I'd like to do starting out
is give you the
take home message.
I like to give you
the take-home message,
tell you what I'm
going to tell you,
tell you the thing
I'm going to tell you,
and then tell you
what I taught you.
So there's a little bit of
teacher training mixed in
with this workshop as well.
All right, so take-home message.
So the take-home message is
that understanding stereotype
threat and wise criticism
is essential for being
a good mentor,
supervisor, and teacher,
and helps with being a good
human being, I think, as well.
So that's the message.
And you might think,
OK, I'm buying in,
but I have no idea what you're
talking about with stereotype
threat.
So let's go there first.
All right.
So let's look at
some definitions.
First, let's look at stereotype.
So stereotype is a prevalent
belief about a specific type
of individuals or a
way of doing things,
which may or may
not reflect reality.
So most people can
think of stereotypes.
Stereotypes can be
positive or negative.
Most people think of
negative stereotypes,
but actually they
can be positive.
So an example of a
positive stereotype
is that MIT students are smart.
I've been here almost 20
years, MIT students are smart.
That's a positive stereotype.
Stereotypes can
be based in truth.
That is pretty true that
MIT students are smart.
What about a
negative stereotype?
What is an example of
a negative stereotype?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So most
people see that jocks
are dumb or not so bright.
So that's an example
of negative stereotype.
CATHY L. DRENNAN: Yes, and in
my experience, that's not true.
There are a lot of
very athletic people--
something that some people
don't know about MIT
is that most people
participate in sports here.
So yeah, so a negative one.
Again, they can be positive,
they can be negative,
they can be largely
true, or not so true.
I also want to introduce the
idea of unconscious bias,
because people are
talking a lot about this.
And actually, when I
started this training,
no one was talking about this
term, and now it's the term.
So let's talk about that.
So it's defined as
social stereotypes
about certain groups that
individuals form outside
of their conscious awareness.
So in other words, they
don't know that they
hold these stereotypes.
Unconscious bias.
And I think people
like this term
because it's takes
the pressure off.
I didn't know I have it,
therefore, I'm not responsible.
It's all good.
But today, we're really
getting in there,
and I feel like I've been doing
this training for a while,
so I've become acutely
aware of just how
many stereotypes I have.
So this is not about, oh, if
it were true, freeing ourselves
of these things.
No.
It's about making ourselves
aware that we have them,
and acting in such a way that
we can counter the harm of it.
All right.
So stereotype threat
is the perceived risk
of confirming a
negative stereotype.
So say, as a female driver
you do something stupid,
and have a whole bunch
of men honking at you.
Right?
You're like, oh, I didn't
want to let the world--
you feel pressure of doing
everything perfectly,
because you don't want to play
into the negative idea there.
All right.
So that's what
stereotype threat is.
And I think stereotype threat
is still a good term for it,
because unconscious bias
threat doesn't really work.
OK, so we're back
to stereotypes.
All right.
So what are we going
to talk about today?
So we're going to talk
more about these terms.
We're going to
talk about the fact
that stereotype threat can
lead to underperformance.
So I'm going to show you
data to support this idea.
We're going to
talk about the fact
that stereotype threat
can lead to the idea
that you're being
judged unfairly.
Sometimes you might
be judged unfairly,
and sometimes you're not
being judged unfairly,
but stereotype threat
can lead to that feeling
whether or not it's true.
Everyone can be a victim
of stereotype threat,
and everyone has stereotypes.
So it affects all of us.
We all hold stereotypes,
we all can be
victims of stereotype threat.
This training is really
for everyone in the room.
And I have to say, this
is not just about gender,
it's not just about race.
It's about anything that
might make us feel different,
anything that might make
us feel under a microscope.
If we're different in any way
from the others around us,
this can affect everybody.
So it's for everyone.
This is the bad news.
What about the good news?
There's always good news.
There's wise criticism.
So this has been shown to
alleviate the negative aspects
of stereotype threat.
So what is it?
So wise criticism is
criticism where you explicitly
let somebody know
that they are capable,
or you believe they're
capable, of a higher
level of achievement.
And there is data to suggest
this goes a long way.
Again, if you can create
this environment of trust,
if the individuals
in your classroom
feel that you believe in
them, you can criticize them--
I mean, this is important
in Mentoring Lab.
Criticism is how we learn.
When we don't do well,
we learn from that.
It's all healthy and good.
But we have to make sure that
any criticism is delivered
in such a way that
the person recognizes
that we believe in them.
Again, back to the student
who never had a TA--
we need everyone to know that
we believe that the person is
able to do the work.
And so, that is one way to
mitigate the negative effects.
All right.
So I don't know if I told
you this ahead of time,
but this is an
interactive training.
So we want everyone
to participate,
and think about how this has
affected me or someone I know.
So what we're going
to do in a minute
is you're going to pair share.
Find a group of two or three,
and turn to your neighbor
and recall a time
when you might have
felt judged by some
superficial characteristic.
So it could be age,
it could be anything.
So think about that or--
and maybe and/or,
you can do both--
you are worried about confirming
a negative stereotype.
So that's the assignment.
Think about it a little bit.
You'll talk to your neighbor.
I'll give you about
five minutes or so.
And then we'll come
back in a group,
and hopefully some of
you will feel comfortable
sharing your experiences
with a larger group,
and we can talk about it.
All right.
So let's take a few minutes,
find someone, share a story.
AUDIENCE: So do you guys have
any experiences like that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
I guess one of mine
that I started being really
aware of when I started
grad school was that I was
really worried about being
taken seriously as a scientist,
if I had a meaningful hobbies
outside of work.
AUDIENCE: So I guess for
me, when I came to MIT,
I was really scared by
the fact that there were
few people that looked like me.
And so, that put like a
lot of pressure on me,
and I felt that I had to
carry a whole race on my back.
And also, I can
remember one meeting
that I had with one
of the professors,
and she was telling
me that, I know
that you come from
a small college,
and that your
classmates are going
to be from Berkeley and
Harvard, and so it might be
right for you at the beginning.
And I feel that
really, really impacted
how I performed in
some of my classes,
and I wish that I had never
had that conversation.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, being from
a smaller school was harder.
I was also from
a smaller school,
and in classes I was
always thinking--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
Can I perform as
well as other people?
AUDIENCE: As well.
Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then being
told that you might not.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So yeah, so you
question yourself.
Sometimes you feel like you
don't really belong here.
And so, yeah, it can be
hard for some people.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I had a very
similar experience to yours.
I was directly told that
students from Puerto Rico
don't really do that well
in first year classes.
And so, when I while I was
never doing terribly in class,
I felt like I didn't have to
necessarily do well at all.
So I would actually not try
as hard as I should have too.
Just do well.
AUDIENCE: Because that's what
they were expecting, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think the other problem--
I've heard many people that
have had the same experience.
So it's sort of like--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I wish
that some of the professors
would understand that they're
not generally helping you
when saying these things.
And maybe a training like
this wouldn't help them a lot.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because were
they trying to-- they're
coming from a place
of trying to help you.
AUDIENCE: I think internally--
yeah, I think their
intention was to help,
but I think it's just--
AUDIENCE: Misguided.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's true.
AUDIENCE: So a time
that I was worried
about confirming a negative
stereotype was when I first
started graduate school.
I was coming from a primarily
undergraduate institution.
I had never been at a
big research university.
And so, I didn't really
know what to expect
or what I was
getting myself into.
And I guess, when people
first explained to me
what the expectations were
in terms of how much I should
work, and what
vacation policies were,
the first time they told me
I literally laughed out loud.
I didn't think they could
possibly be serious.
And then I realized, whoa,
I might be in over my head.
And once I realized that,
I was like, oh, man.
People are going to think that
I'm not serious about my job,
and I don't know what I'm doing.
So I had to pretend
all of a sudden
that I was all focused on
science, because I didn't want
people to think that I
wasn't taking it seriously
because of my background.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no, I feel
the same way coming to MIT.
Especially, coming
in for me, confirming
the negative stereotype,
also just being
judged for my physical
attributes as a woman of color.
I feel like there's a lot of
stereotypes, negative, around
my ethnicity and my race.
And one of the things that
I heard a lot of times
it's the idea that,
you speak well,
or you're articulate
for a black woman.
And this is not only my story.
I've had a number
of my colleagues
say the same thing to me.
So it's something that's
just constantly being battled
against a negative stereotype.
And also this idea
that coming in--
a combination of
my, I like to call
it an intersectionality
of all my personalities
and all my identities.
So I'm a woman of color.
I am from the Caribbean.
I went to a small
school, but I'm not only
just a small
liberal arts school,
I went to a small HBCU, which
is a historically Black college
and university.
And I feel like all those
combinations also mix.
Get into a classroom,
and being one
of the only persons
of color makes
me feel extra pressure
for confirming
these negative stereotypes
that are thought
against people of color.
So in the classrooms I
try not to ask questions,
because I don't
want to out myself
as not being smart, or not as
much as my other colleagues
who might have went
to bigger schools,
and have had targeted classes
on this particular subject,
for example.
So it's been definitely the idea
of being the "face of the race"
also, because you don't want to
spoil it for other people who
come along.
So it's been a
little bit like you
feel like you have
to not ask questions,
you're not out yourself.
Anything you say might prove
that negative stereotype,
and it's a lot of
pressure to do.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, totally.
AUDIENCE: I can't necessarily
relate to your experience,
but the flip side of
the coin on that is I
do have one sliver
of an experience
where I kind of feel
like I can relate
to what you're talking about.
And that's when we're having
conversations about diversity,
I feel like I don't
want to say something
that might sound ignorant,
or naive, or uninformed.
Because I feel like if I end
up saying something stupid
and offending someone, I set
the conversation back a step,
and then I end up
confirming the stereotype
that all white men don't care
about improving diversity
in science.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, well,
that's very understandable.
And I feel like it's
very crippling too,
because he might have really
good experiences that you want
to share, and good
contributions that you
could make in that sense.
And you can't do it because
of that negative stereotype.
You're really confirming that.
So it's definitely
very crippling.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think it is
detrimental to the whole cause,
because it takes
everybody, right?
AUDIENCE: It does, it does.
AUDIENCE: For all participating.
AUDIENCE: It is.
AUDIENCE: OK, so I think--
let me see.
Thinking about a
time when I felt
judged about a
negative stereotype.
So I'm pretty short.
I don't know if you noticed when
I walked in, but I think that--
and I look pretty young.
My sister's two years
younger, but I'm always
considered the
younger sister, and I
think that that's
led me to always
be really afraid of confirming
that women are weak,
or not able to do
things on their own.
So I'm very conscious
of not asking for help
with certain situations.
If I can't reach things
or things like that,
I know where all
the step-stools are.
Or I've been known to climb
on shelves in grocery stores
instead of asking for help.
And it's one of those situations
where I'm very much afraid,
and I often lead with the
fact that I have a black belt
in Taekwondo to
kind of help paint
this picture that I actually
can do things for myself.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I feel
that, because I'm
literally the same way,
including the black belt.
(LAUGHS)
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's one
thing I lead with.
AUDIENCE: It's
something that kind
of shocks people, because
they're like, oh, you're
so little.
I don't know.
I feel like I'm always
so worried about the fact
that just because
I'm so little--
and I've always
been this little,
it's not like I was the
tallest person in my class--
that I need to be able to show
that I can take care of myself,
and be independent, because
of this stereotype that women
can't, and need a
man to make sure
that things are OK for them.
So, yeah.
That's where I'm at with that.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: It's OK.
I can't get taller.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, well,
when I was six years old,
I actually used to race cars.
And I remember
there was a day when
I should've gotten
second place in a race,
but because the three
boys in front of me
crashed right before the end of
the race, they gave me fifth,
because they were in
second and third and fourth
before the flag went down.
But then I crossed
the line first,
so I should have gotten second.
Anyway, after this
whole situation is over,
one of the boys came
up to me and was like,
oh, well, you're a girl.
Of course you can't
get second place.
And I was like, excuse me?
Yes, that was over 20 years ago.
AUDIENCE: And that
was when you were six.
AUDIENCE: That was
when I was six.
AUDIENCE: How old was the--
AUDIENCE: I think he was seven.
So, yeah.
It's still there.
Good times.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CATHY L. DRENNAN: All right.
Let's come back as a group.
There was a lot of
good discussion.
I can't wait to hear
what you're going to say.
But I thought I would start
out by sharing a story
to get us going.
So in the first category, a
time that you were judged.
So I think back to
a time when I was
graduating from Vassar College.
These are the old days, where if
you announced who got an award,
they'd post a piece of
paper in the student union.
There was no email thing
to send out to people.
And so, everyone
gathered around the list
of people who had been
named Phi Beta Kappa.
And I was really excited that I
had been named Phi Beta Kappa.
And so, I'm leaving after
having looked at the list,
and I saw someone
who I hadn't really
talked to since freshman year.
He was in my dorm, and it
was one of those things
like freshman year, where
the entire floor of your dorm
like goes everywhere together.
You go to the dining
hall together,
you go to parties
together, because there's
this herd effect.
Anyway, this guy Phillip
had been in my herd,
but I'd never actually
talked to him.
So he walks up to me and he
looks at me, and he said,
you were on that list.
And I said, yes.
And he just looks at
me, and then he said,
it never occurred to
me that you were smart.
[SOFT LAUGHTER]
I mean you could just
see the wheels turning
like, her name is on the list!
Her name is on that list!
She's smart?
And I just thought like, what
did I do that this was such--
It's like, oh, whatever.
If they saw it, they might
not have ever thought
about it one way or
another, but clearly, he
had formed an extremely strong
opinion that there was no way
that I could be smart,
and this was just
messing with his worldview, the
fact my name was on the list.
So what was it about
me that was just
so inconceivable to this
person that I could be smart?
OK, so in the second category,
pretend you're at MIT.
In the Chemistry Department at
the point where I was coming up
for tenure, there was
one female professor
who had gotten
tenure, and then they
had hired two more
in with tenure.
So I was number two.
Case study.
Would she get tenure?
And I felt like they
were all watching.
Is she going to meetings?
How many papers
has she published?
Is she going to make it?
What do you think?
Lay in the bets.
What are the odds?
I don't know.
There probably were odds.
I don't know what they are.
I never want to know.
But I just felt like,
man, my not getting tenure
it's not really
about me anymore.
It's, can women get tenure?
And it was all riding
on my shoulders.
I was going to
provide the answer,
and people would make
decisions about their lives,
I was afraid, based
on whether it worked.
Oh, it didn't work for her.
I'm not sure I
want to go forward.
That is a lot of
pressure when you
feel like you're carrying other
people besides yourself around.
So that's an example for me.
All right.
So you don't have to have
as profound examples,
but everyone has some
Phillip in their life, right?
Has somebody like that.
So let's hear.
Who wants to share about this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in addition
to being a scientist,
I'm also a musician, and
when I got to grad school
I felt really insecure
about having this hobby,
and thought that I might not be
seen as serious of a scientist
because I like to
play music as well.
And so, I downplayed my hobby,
and didn't join ensembles
as much.
But even then, when I
started in grad school
participating in
an ensemble, I was
really worried I'd
confirm the stereotype
that just because I
was also a musician,
I was less serious
of a scientist.
CATHY L. DRENNAN: Yeah,
thanks for bringing that up.
I think that's a
really great example.
So it's just we
have these ideas,
and it's like we have these
square holes and round holes,
and we're trying to
bat everybody into it.
There's many different
things that people
can do if they're scientists.
There's many different
hobbies and other interests
that they can have,
and we shouldn't
have such a narrow definition.
So someone else?
I heard lots of
discussion going on.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in
terms of being judged
by someone for a superficial
characteristic, as an African--
Afro-Caribbean I should say--
woman in the scientific
setting, I feel like one thing
I get a lot is that,
you speak very well.
And usually I'm like, for?
Why?
But I think it's definitely
I'm clearly a minority,
so basically there's
some negative stereotypes
about whole women of color
should present themselves,
and I don't fit in
to that stereotype.
So every time I do give a talk
or I do express my opinions,
people say I'm very well-spoken.
And this is not
only my own case.
I've heard a number
of my friends
say the same things, even
sometimes from their advisors
and people who have gone
through a lot of students.
So that's one case
where I feel like I've
been judged superficially for
a superficial characteristic.
Another thing of confirming
a negative stereotype
also comes back to my ethnicity.
You mentioned feeling like you
carry the weight of persons
on your back, and
thinking about being,
again, an African-American
woman, most of the time
the only one in a room.
Not today.
[LAUGHTER]
That's great.
But most of the time it's
being the only one in the room.
And especially coming
from a small college,
I also felt coming into my
first chemistry classes,
there was this pressure
that I put on myself to not
confirm these negative
stereotypes about people
of color in terms of
that they're not smart,
or they're not good
at math or science,
and I didn't belong there.
And it's not because people
around me said anything.
It was definitely
internal that I
felt like I had to
not answer a question,
or not ask a question because
I didn't want to look as if I
didn't know something,
or all my classmates
knew it and I didn't know it.
So it's that weight
of one, not confirming
that negative stereotype,
and also not spoiling it
for everybody else
who comes after me
who is a URM from an HBCU.
CATHY L. DRENNAN: Yeah.
Those are both really
great examples.
Thank you for sharing those.
I think that really gets
to the heart of what
we're trying to talk about.
Feeling judged, and you
get these compliments--
and I've gotten this
for some of the talks.
It's like, that was
actually pretty good!
What was your expectation
ahead of time?
Or, you spoke well!
Like, thank you.
Yeah, and that
extra pressure to--
who else is coming
along with us?
So thank you for sharing those.
That's really great.
Maybe one more.
Does someone else have
something you want to share?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When I
participate in conversations
about improving
diversity in science,
a lot of times I'll worry that
if I ask an uninformed question
or make a naive suggestion that
I'll set the conversation back
or offend somebody,
and ultimately
confirm the stereotype that
white male scientists aren't
serious about improving
diversity in science.
So then I'll tell
myself, just sit back
and listen to other people.
And then as soon as
I start doing that,
I'll start to worry, how
are people perceiving this?
Do I look sullen and like
I don't care about this?
And then, again,
I worry that I'm
confirming a
different stereotype
about white men in science.
[SOFT LAUGHTER]
So I think ultimately,
it's important for me
to remember that my voice is
overrepresented in science,
and I should make a concerted
effort to actively listen
to other people's
perspectives, but also
recognize that by spending so
much mental energy worrying
about how other people
might be perceiving me,
I'm ultimately undermining
my own ability to make
a positive contribution towards
improving diversity in science.
CATHY L. DRENNAN: Thank
you for sharing that.
I think that's a
really good point.
I've had people, when I've done
this training before, a man say
that he felt very much under
sort of stereotype threat
when he was taking a
woman's study course,
and he was the only
guy in the class.
And that sometimes he
felt like if he spoke up
and what he said, that
he was going to really
be judged by it, and it was just
a very uncomfortable situation.
And I really feel like
what we want to do here
is start the discussion.
Everyone's voice
is so important.
And sometimes it
drives me crazy when
I'm hearing about women
in science, it's like, OK,
you, woman, go fix this.
It's like, I can't do this.
I think we all need to
be talking about this
and doing this together.
These problems are not
problems for women to solve,
or for people of color to solve.
We want to improve science.
We all need to be part
of this discussion,
and everyone's voice
is so important.
So we want to have a
situation where everyone feels
like they can
speak, and everyone
is going to listen to what
other people have to say.
So very on point.
Thank you very much.
All right.
So I think we should
get back, and we
want to go back because I
have some data to show you.
And this is MIT, and
we're scientists,
so let's look at some data.
All right.
So there is a book by
Claude Steele called
Whistling Vivaldi, and
Other Clues as to How
Stereotypes Affect Us.
Claude Steele is often viewed
as the father of stereotype
threat, really coming
up with this concept
and making people aware of it.
And his book has a
lot of data in it.
A lot of different studies.
He summarizes studies that many
different people have done.
So some of the studies are more
social studies, some of them
are more in the
neuroscience area.
So some studies that
he describes actually
look at brain waves and
blood flow in the brain.
And so, they will put people
under stereotype threat,
and there's a variety
of ways you can do it,
poking at those
negative stereotypes
that we talked about, and
then actually watch blood flow
or brain activity.
And you can see movement
from the part of the brain
where it's about
logic and reasoning,
to, when people are
under stereotype
threat, the part of the brain
that's about fear, about fight
or flight.
And so when you're
in the classroom,
the goal is all the students
their brain is with logic,
right?
They're processing
the information
and they're learning.
You don't want people
in your classroom
where the brain is very
anxious, and worrying about
whether you belong and
whether you can do it.
So there's an actual biological
reason why stereotype threat
can lead to underperformance.
Your brain's not doing what
your brain should be doing.
It should be in the logic
area, not in the fear area.
So this is one thing that's
talked about in his book.
So anyway.
So some of the
studies that he did,
it was groups of
female undergrads.
Stanford quite a good school.
People who get in there,
very smart people.
And so, he looked at the SAT
scores of a group of women,
and then he divided
them into two groups.
And they should have
equal math abilities
based on their SAT scores.
So for one group,
he either reminded
them of their gender before
the exam, and in some case,
didn't say anything at all.
But in the second
group, he told them
that the exam had
no gender bias.
And so, he would
start out saying,
well, you may have heard
that women often underperform
on SATs in the math, but
we've been working here,
and we've created
a math exam that
has no gender bias,
so everyone can do up
to their full ability.
There's nothing
holding you back.
And what was really interesting
that this group performed
very well compared to the other
group that was either reminded
of their gender, or
sometimes nothing
was said about gender at all.
So when these women
thought that they
could do as well
as they could do,
they over-performed or
outperformed the other group.
So there's a number
of these kinds
of studies done
in different ways
showing again that
if you feel like you
can reach your full
performance, you get there.
But if you're reminded
of these issues,
and that you might be confirming
a negative stereotype,
or you're worried
about confirming
a negative stereotype, it
can lead to poor performance.
All right.
So stereotype threat can
lead to underperformance,
which is a problem in
a classroom, for sure.
The other point that
I brought up before,
and I want to come back
to, is that it can also
lead to a feeling of
being judged unfairly.
And this is one of
my favorite studies,
and it's back from the 1980s.
So in this study they
said, all right, we
want to address the
differences-- how people
are treated if they have some
kind of physical disfigurement,
in particular, a
scar on your face.
So he said, what
we're going to do
is we're going to bring in a
makeup artist from Hollywood,
they're going to put
a scar on your face,
and then we're going to
send you into this room
and we're going to
watch the interactions.
And we want you to
tell us, are you
being treated
differently because you
have this scar on your face?
So the volunteers sat
in front of the mirror.
They had the makeup
artist come and this scar
was put on their face.
And then right before they
were supposed to go in,
the makeup artist
came back and said,
we're just going to touch it up,
make sure you're ready to go.
They removed it entirely,
but the person had no idea.
They thought that the scar
was still on the face.
Went into the room, there
was a discussion, came out.
The volunteer said, oh, I was
treated entirely differently
with this scar on my face.
And other people had watched.
There was nothing going on.
But they were just sensing--
they were looking
for signs that they
were being treated unfairly.
And when you look for
things, sometimes you
can find them or interpret them,
when they don't really exist.
So right now, some
people are sitting,
might have their arms
crossed a little bit.
And if I were an insecure
person, I could say,
that person's sitting
there is thinking
there is nothing this woman has
to tell me that I want to hear.
And they just are
sitting like that.
But then I also know it's
a little cold in this room.
Someone might just
be a little bit cold,
and that's why they're
sitting like this, right?
You can interpret
all sorts of things.
If you're looking for a sign
that somebody is questioning
you, you might be able to find
it even when it's not there.
And sometimes it's really there.
Sometimes people are judging.
Oh, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
We can have stories later.
But sometimes they're not.
So I just want to
give you one example.
So this is the other counter--
a guide to reducing
stereotype threat
and maximizing student
performance, also
a guide to Cathy's most
embarrassing moments.
But there was one time I was
meeting with a professor,
I was pre-tenure.
Again, I wanted to get tenure.
Very nervous about
this whole thing.
And so, this person in my
field, likely a letter-writer,
is coming to my office.
And I was really excited.
So I was like, I had results
that he was going to like.
I knew he would
like these results.
I printed him out,
like these slides.
I had everything all ready.
I thought through my spiel.
I was psyched.
He he came.
And so he came
in, he's like, I'm
so glad you're here visiting.
This is great.
I have these new results
I want to show you,
and I pull this out.
And he goes, you know,
I was sort of wondering,
how's your experience been here?
I was like, good, good.
Very good.
Now, we had this result--
and he's like, but I
had some questions.
Do you feel like
you've been treated OK?
30 minutes went by.
He did not look at a
single result that I had.
And I just thought,
this guy has just
decided that there is no
result that I could possibly
have that would be interesting
enough to pay attention to.
And so, he's just going to
spend this half hour chatting
about this and that, and things
about me being a junior faculty
member, whatever, and just
clearly disrespectful of me.
So that was my take.
Find out later he has a son
that's starting as an Assistant
Professor.
He wants to give his son advice,
but he hasn't been an Assistant
Professor for a long time.
Things have changed.
So he said, when I go to
talk to Cathy Drennan,
I'm going to ask her
a lot of questions
about being an
Assistant Professor,
because she has been so
hugely successful that I
want to take how
she's done things
and tell my son about it.
So I could not have
been more wrong.
I thought he was
judging me unfairly.
Turns out, that was
not the case at all.
And so, because other people--
I've one male professor explain
to another male professor
my data without involving
me in the discussion,
because what could I
possibly know about it?
So I've had these
experiences, but then I'm
looking for these
experiences in other places,
and sometimes they're
not there at all.
Sometimes a person
is being respectful.
So when you feel like you're
under stereotype threat,
you can sometimes take a
situation entirely incorrectly.
Now, he could have
also said, hey, Cathy,
you've been so successful.
Let me ask you questions.
That could have-- but whatever.
Whatever.
So I think this
is something also
to think about, that people
are looking to each other like,
do you trust?
Do you believe in me?
Do you trust what
I'm going to say?
We're trying to get
a sense of this.
And sometimes we
may get it wrong,
and sometimes it
may not be there,
but everyone in the
classroom is not the same.
Even if you treat
everyone the same,
they're not always the
same, because people
are coming in with baggage.
And I've got baggage,
let me tell you.
I got some baggage.
I'll put my baggage up
against your baggage,
but everyone is coming
in with something.
All right.
So I think you already know
the answer to this one.
Who can be a victim
of stereotype threat?
ENTIRE AUDIENCE: Everyone!
CATHY L. DRENNAN: Yes, everyone.
[LAUGHTER]
In fact, studies show that it's
the strongest students that
are the most affected.
So if you care about
what people think of you,
if you care about doing
well, if you're ambitious,
if you want to do important
things in your life,
you care about these
kinds of things.
And if you're at
a place that has
a good reputation,
like MIT, that
can lead to imposter syndrome.
So most you've probably
heard of imposter syndrome
before, but this
idea that somehow
you were only accepted to MIT--
your name is like
someone else, and they
weren't going to accept you.
But then they made this mistake
and then somehow you got in,
said the person who was
below you in the line when
they were supposed to get in.
And that everyone else here
is brilliant except for you,
and someday that
people are going
to figure out that you're
trying to look like a nerd--
or a horse.
You know, you've got
your horse stockings on
and your horse cape.
Or your zebra cape
and your zebra
stockings, but you're
not really a zebra.
And that you're wearing
your nerdiest clothes,
but you're really
not an MIT nerd.
So this is something that so
many people at top universities
are affected by, and
this is really important
when people are, again,
under stereotype threat.
They're feeling like, man, I'm
the only one who doesn't really
belong here.
So imposter syndrome.
OK.
Another teaching tip, because
you'll all be teaching.
Before you teach on
something, look up
what it says on Wikipedia.
Just double check what it says.
So what do you
think Wikipedia says
of the people who are most
affected by imposter syndrome?
What particular group?
Any guesses?
Men?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
Graduate students.
Someone has been
googling Wikipedia.
That is, in fact, correct.
So a lot of people
say, oh, it's women.
But the data actually shows that
men and women suffer equally,
which is not really
my experience.
I think that if this is true,
it's just that women talk about
it all the time and men don't.
But apparently, the
data shows that it's
equal among men and women.
And it is commonly
associated with academics
and widely found among
graduate students.
So again, it's
people who want to do
important things with her life.
Graduate school.
Anyone who's in
graduate school--
that's a pretty big deal that
you're in graduate school.
So you really you care
about what people think.
You care about
whether you belong.
You're thinking, how did I
end up in graduate school,
how did I end up at MIT,
and do I really belong here?
So these are natural
things for people to think.
And I will tell you
that a number of faculty
have reported that yes they
suffer from imposter syndrome.
I think anyone who is honest
will say that they do.
So this is a big problem.
All right.
So let's do another exercise.
You might have wondered about
the title of Claude Steele's
book that I mentioned,
Whistling Vivaldi.
Where does that title come from?
So he explains the title,
which is a good thing,
because it is an unusual title.
So he said that it
comes from a story
that he heard of this young
African-American man who
was in the South
Side of Chicago,
and this man was a musician.
And he was walking
one night, and there
was an elderly couple walking
on the street right near him.
And they saw him
walking near them,
and he saw them walking faster.
And they were an elderly
couple, so they were really
trying to walk fast.
And he felt kind of bad
because they were kind of old.
And so, he wanted to
kind of yell out at them,
you do not need
to worry about me.
I'm not going to do
anything bad to you.
But yelling that probably
would be even more terrifying.
So we thought about
it and he said,
I'm going to start
whistling Vivaldi,
actually whistling
the music of Vivaldi.
And so, he started whistling
the music and the couple
slowed their pace,
because they thought,
this is someone who
is classically trained
or loves classical music.
Not so much associated
with someone who's
going to steal my handbag.
And so, they relaxed.
So in this book, Steele
asserts that we all whistle
Vivaldi from time to time.
We all try to fit in and
make other people more
comfortable with us.
So this is a little bit of a
harder thing to think about.
Have you ever whistled Vivaldi?
Have you ever tried to fit in?
And let me just give you
an example that I heard
to help you think about this.
So one student said
that he was actually
from a very religious
family, and he
was used to praying
before eating a meal.
But in the lunch room of
a science building somehow
that felt weird to
pray before eating.
A lot of people have
this idea that if you're
very religious
that somehow that's
counter to being a
scientist, because you have
faith vs. Scientific facts.
And he wasn't sure how people
would judge him if they
knew about his religion.
So even though he
really did want to pray,
he stopped doing
it because he just
thought he wouldn't fit in.
It would make other
people feel uncomfortable.
He wasn't sure how
others would feel,
and if they would accept him
the same way as a scientist
if he prayed before a meal.
So that's an example
of whistling Vivaldi.
So think about it for a minute.
Find your partner.
Talk to them about whether
this has ever happened to you,
and then we'll
come back together
as a group in a few minutes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so when I
think about whistling Vivaldi,
for me, the point where
I feel like I'm really
changing or trying to
conform to an appearance
is pretty much any
time after 9/11.
When I go through
the airports I'm
always conscious of what
people might be thinking about
based on my skin color.
And so, when I go through,
every day right before I travel,
I shave my beard off.
I try to be dressed
up a little nicer.
And I even feel myself being
a little extra friendly
to TSA gate agents,
because I feel
like there's this negative
stereotype hanging over me.
And I feel like even
though it's on my mind,
and it feels sometimes like it
might be on everybody else's.
I feel like maybe my ID's
looked at a little differently,
and things like that.
So I make sure they can
hear my American accent,
make sure they don't
see any facial hair.
Things like that.
I try to be extra
nice, extra polite.
Just feeling a little
more nervous, I think,
is really the cause
of that as well.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's
really good example.
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: Mine would be
in professional settings,
especially at conferences or
any presentation of some sort,
I try to cover my tattoos
the best way I can.
And I also have a nose
ring, and so sometimes I
would wear like
a clear nose ring
so people only if they're
really up close to me
can see that I have one.
And that's just to mitigate
any stereotype threats
that people have.
Because you walk
into a room and you
have tattoos visible,
or your piercings,
especially on your
face, and that
can lead people to think
differently about you
and what you're
capable of doing.
And so, I just
want to lessen that
and have people look past that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think that's
a really good example.
I mean, it's all the
same thing, is we
feel like our appearances
are telling something,
and we're really worried
that the message is
going to be negative there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So when have we
whistled Vivaldi?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think I especially
do it whenever
I'm with friends and family.
So since English isn't
my native language,
but I feel like I can
speak it pretty well,
so then whenever I go back
home, my friends and family
don't always speak
English, I actually
intentionally mispronounce
certain words just
to keep that
connection with them.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Since I've been
gone for like a few months,
and seeing me every
so often, I just
want them to feel like I'm
still the same me I was.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then
when I'm here,
I always try to pronounce
everything super well,
so that's not an issue when
someone's talking to me.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] similar?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
so I guess for me,
one of the big things
about grad school
was that I sometimes felt
pretty isolated as one of very
few women in our department.
And so, over time, I realized I
started dressing more and more
like a man, to fit
in and to be taken
more seriously, and
just so that I didn't
have to feel as different.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So, yes, like with that,
I feel like I've always
wanted to be who I am, and I
don't want to be somebody else.
So I guess, along
those lines, I've
had one conversation
with one of my professors
where she was explaining that
in research, when people were
giving presentations,
they usually
wore light colors like
gray, and white, or black,
and that you shouldn't
be too colorful.
One time we were going
into a conference,
and I was wearing red.
I was like really colorful,
and then she was like, wow.
I mean, that's not
what we talked about.
I'm like, yeah.
Science can be colorful too.
AUDIENCE: That's great. (LAUGHS)
AUDIENCE: I want to be who I am.
And the next minute, I saw a
professor, he was so colorful,
like red and orange
all over the place.
I was like, yes.
That's what I'm talking about.
Be who you are.
Be free.
And that's how a
science should be.
People should be comfortable
in their skin and who they are.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: When I'm meeting
new scientists, especially
younger ones, or people who I
might have to mentor or train,
if they ever start to open
up about an experience
where they felt discriminated
against or harassed,
I can't necessarily
relate to that experience,
but I do want to convey
that they can trust me,
and that I'll listen
to them, and I'll
help them in whatever way.
Because I can't really
share a personal experience.
A lot of times I'll basically
turned to relevant literature,
like the book Whistling Vivaldi.
And I'll try to communicate,
I'm on your side and I'm safe,
by talking about a subject
that communicates to them
I'm putting effort
into this and I care.
AUDIENCE: Oh, that's
a really good one.
It makes a lot of sense for me.
It's more just going back
again to my identities.
I have an accent, because
I'm from the Caribbean--
and I feel like this
is common for lots
of international students
in the scientific setting--
I definitely try to put
on a more, quote, unquote,
American accent, to ensure
that my audience is not
being distracted by
my accent, but really
focusing on the science,
and really trying
to be more scientific,
quote, unquote.
And the other thing, in
terms of physical appearance,
I have a lot of hair.
[LAUGHTER]
It's very contained right
now, but it's really big.
So definitely, in
scientific settings,
I definitely try to pull
it back to look more
what, quote, unquote,
would be [INAUDIBLE] kept.
It's really kind
of weird, but yeah,
so you'll definitely see me
either my hair slicked back
in a scientific setting, versus
when you probably will see me
in lab, or something like that.
So that's definitely the
way I whistle Vivaldi,
because, again, I
don't want people
to be distracted by
my hair, or thinking
I don't look professional.
I don't want that to
detract from what I'm saying
and the science that I'm doing.
So that's definitely
another occasion
when I whistle Vivaldi.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that
makes a lot of sense.
AUDIENCE: So I guess for
the whistling Vivaldi,
I did have an example
that reminded me of this
when I was an undergrad.
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: So I joined
a lab my freshman year,
and I have always been more
traditionally feminine.
My, I don't know,
style dressing.
And I kind of noticed I was one
of the only women on the floor,
and I knew I stood out.
And I specifically
remember that there
was a professor who asked
me what I was doing around
on the lab floor, and told me I
didn't like the research type.
And that really stuck with
me, and after that, I really
changed.
I had my lab style and then
my everyday Lindsay style.
AUDIENCE: (LAUGHS)
AUDIENCE: Whenever
I was in the lab,
I would always wear very
baggy clothes, tennis shoes,
my hair tied back.
And I felt like my glasses made
me look more studious, so I
would always wear my glasses.
It's just something I
was very conscious of.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I would specifically
dressed in one way
when I was being a scientist,
and I would dress another way
when I was in my outside life.
AUDIENCE: It's like not
easy, because in some setting
you're judged for
being dressed up.
In other settings you're
judged for being dressed down.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
totally get that.
Yeah so, in my case, I think
it's more about my race.
I personally have a stereotype
that Asian women that
are recently immigrated
are more reserved, quiet,
and, I don't know, obedient.
And although no one actually
ever negatively judged
me for that, I'm constantly
afraid to confirm
that negative stereotype.
So even if I'm not really
that kind of person,
I try to be very vocal and
talkative, especially when I'm
surrounded by people that I'm
meeting for the first time,
so I'm giving like an
impression that I want
to engage in the conversation.
Yeah, it was not an easy
thing, but I've been doing it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CATHY L. DRENNAN: All right.
So I'm just going to start out.
I'm going to give
you one example.
This time it's not
mine, but I think
that it was one of the
ones that someone suggested
that really resonated with me.
So I want to share it.
So this sense of
feeling the need
to suffer for your science,
and that other people
see someone that are
talking about how much they
suffered for their science.
And instead of just
saying, wait a minute,
I sleep eight hours a night.
They're like, yeah I gotta
get in on this suffering
for my science thing.
So an example,
someone was talking
about how they knew that
this person was going
on this ski trip
over the weekend,
but before they left lab to
go on the ski trip, instead
of saying, hey, see all Monday.
I'm going skiing.
They're going out like carrying
these journals and papers.
And they're just
like, oh, I got a lot
of reading to do this weekend.
Does anyone have a cart?
I can barely carry it.
I'm going to be
reading all weekend.
This is a scheme.
What's going on?
But it's like, if you're
really a scientist,
if you're a true scientist,
if you're a real scientist,
you suffer.
You have no hobbies.
You work day and night in
the cold room, in the dark.
I mean, you're just
36-hour experiments.
There's no time to shower.
There's no time to sleep.
And instead of just saying
and sending a message
to maybe new people in
lab, and undergrads,
and I think this has come up,
especially with women, that
like if you do not give
of yourself completely,
you're not a, quote,
real scientist.
And a lot of people who
are thinking about science,
especially women, think, I'd
really like to have a family,
and I know I might be doing a
little more of the caregiving.
So I don't know if
I can do science.
I might have to
do something else.
Because there's
this notion that you
have to suffer so
deeply for your science.
And people buy into this.
They don't want to
be the one saying,
I don't know what's wrong with
you, but I shower every day.
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
They're just like coming
up with something else
that they're saying.
It's like, well, yeah, but
my experiment was even worse!
And I had to walk uphill
both ways to do it, right?
Everyone gets into this
in the whole lab culture,
and they're trying
to outdo themselves
with the degree of suffering.
So that's one
example that came up.
And I do think that these kind
of things-- it sounds funny,
but it's important,
because it sends
a message of what it takes
to be a scientist that is not
really true.
And if we have well-adjusted
human beings doing science,
I'm OK for that.
I think that's a good thing to
have well-adjusted human beings
doing science.
So we have to think a little bit
about fitting into a culture,
and what that is, and
what we do to fit in.
All right.
So that's just one example
that was shared with me
before, which I
thought was a good one.
But it seems like you guys were
having some lively discussion.
So who would like to
start off by sharing
what you were talking about?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so depending
on who I'm talking with,
I actually tune my accent.
For example, when I'm
back home, I intentionally
mispronounce certain words so
that I can talk with my friends
and family.
And then whenever I'm here
in an academic setting,
I try to pronounce
everything correctly.
Yeah.
CATHY L. DRENNAN: Yeah,
so the sort of, I'm
still sort of one of you.
I've gone off to
this place of MIT,
but I'm back having
these conversations.
And then you present a
different side when you're here.
I've heard that a lot, that
sometimes being at a top place,
people feeling
uncomfortable going home,
that the family members
just feel like they
don't want to sound
stupid, so they just
don't know what to
say to you anymore.
It's like, it's still me.
It's OK. (LAUGHS) That's great.
OK.
Anybody else?
Yeah, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
I personally have
a stereotype that Asian women,
especially those who are,
quote, unquote,
fresh off the boat,
are more reserved and quiet.
And while I'm a person who kind
of confirms that stereotype,
when I'm with people that I'm
meeting for the first time,
I try to be a little
more vocal and talkative,
to give an impression
that I want
to engage in this conversation.
And sometimes that
makes you feel bad,
because I'm not true to myself.
So, yeah.
CATHY L. DRENNAN: Yeah, yeah.
People may not
believe this about me,
but I used to be really shy.
[SOFT LAUGHTER]
So, yeah.
So all those years of
imposter syndrome--
all right.
I'm going to wear
my not-shy clothes,
and talk like a not-shy person.
But yeah, I had to really
struggle with that,
and I think it's very hard.
When you are worried
about that stereotype,
it's pushing yourself out.
Being a little more--
so that's it that's a
really, really nice example.
Anyone else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I
have several tattoos,
and I also have a nose piercing.
And when I'm in
professional settings,
especially at conferences, I
try to cover up my tattoos,
and sometimes they even
put in a different nose
ring that's clear so
you really can't see it
unless you're close up.
And I try to do that
in order to not confirm
a negative stereotype of
people who decide to put art
on their body or
have extra piercings,
and to appear more professional,
and that I understand
and know what I'm talking about.
CATHY L. DRENNAN: Yeah, that's
also a really-- everyone's
got really great examples.
That has kind of come up in
[INAUDIBLE] really thinking
about how you're dressed
and other things.
And one time I had
videotapes to use
in freshman chemistry, of
scientists talking about how
they were using chemistry.
And I got all this
feedback because one
of the people in the video
had piercings and tattoos.
And they're like, but that's
not a scientist, right?
But then he talked
so articulately,
and it was mind-blowing.
But we do have
these ideas of what
scientists should look like.
I partly blame Hollywood.
Polyester pants, and the lab
coat, and pocket protectors.
And it turns out scientists
look like everyone else.
But then we worry,
and sometimes try
to fit in, and whistle a
little Vivaldi to hide maybe
some parts of that.
And so, yeah.
Really, really good
examples everyone.
OK.
Let's move on.
Who has stereotypes?
ENTIRE AUDIENCE: Everyone!
CATHY L. DRENNAN: Yeah.
Sorry.
Sorry for the bad news.
But let me show you some data
in case you're not convinced.
All right.
So there's a whole
bunch of studies,
and I'm just going to
tell you about a few
of them that get at
this fact that we all
do have stereotypes.
Because we all live in a
culture, we're all part of it.
We are, in fact, not in
the cold room for 36 hours.
We come out to socialize with
other people at some point,
and so we develop stereotypes.
All right.
So there are these a
bunch of different studies
where they show groups,
multiple different CVs.
And they have one
CV that's clearly
a man's name, another CV
that's clearly a woman's name,
and then they ask this
group, pick the best
candidate for something.
And the data show
that if the see
these are designed to
be very, very similar--
similar kinds of
schools, similar numbers
of publications,
similar awards--
that people will pick the
CV with the man's name
on as being better.
And importantly,
women do this too.
So this idea of, let's put
a woman on every committee
so that we make sure that this
committee is doing the best,
picking the best
candidate, whatever, women
do the exact same thing as men.
They also pick
the male candidate
when the CVs are very similar.
So a lot of these studies were
done in the English profession,
but Joe Handelsman and a bunch
of others in this publication,
in PNAS in 2012, redid
did this CV study,
but it was only for scientists.
So people would say,
scientists are logical, right?
We can't have stereotypes.
We're about facts.
We're about data.
We are so logical
we can't possibly
really have stereotypes.
And so, clear
convincing evidence
that that is, in fact, not true.
Scientists are just like
all other human beings,
as it turns out.
They're people.
Anyhow, so this study.
Loved this study.
Jealous of this study.
Why did I not do this study?
Anyhow.
So what they did is they
took this resume, CV, said it
was for a lab manager position.
They had the name John on
it or the name Jennifer,
and they sent it to
different people,
and then saw what people
thought collectively about John,
and what people thought
collectively about Jennifer.
Exactly the same
CV, so they should
have thought the same
things about both of them,
because it was the same.
But then they compared for
the male name versus female
who's applying for this
lab manager position,
they thought that the
man was more competent,
that the man was more
hireable, and was
going to be easier
to mentor, and also
should get pay to lot more.
Now, again, let me emphasize,
these are identical documents,
except one has the
name John on it,
and one had the
name Jennifer on it.
And they looked at how men
viewed this and how women did.
It was male faculty,
women faculty, again,
for a lab manager position.
Women thought the same thing.
Women thought that the CV
with the name John on it
was a lot more impressive than
the CV with the name Jennifer.
So scientists, the
ivory tower, is just
locked-in people with
the same prejudices
that you find other places.
The same stereotypes.
All right.
OK.
So we need some good news.
I think it's time for good news.
I've convinced you
that you can all
be victims of stereotype threat,
that you all have stereotypes.
Probably, you're all worried
about imposter syndrome.
If you didn't have it
before, I'm sure you do now.
But you know that I have it.
Maybe that means like--
anyway.
Good news.
Wise criticism.
So this can be used to mitigate
the effects of stereotype
threat.
And again, it's criticism
that's delivered in such a way
that students feel like
they're capable of a high level
of achievement, that
students are less defensive
and feel less threatened.
And so, here, again, it's not
about whether there's criticism
or not, it's really about how
that criticism is delivered.
So I'll just give
you a brief example
what I think about here.
When I started as
Assistant Professor,
it was the first time I was
writing a paper from my lab
that my advisor's not
deciding it's OK or not.
This is for me.
So I gave it to one of
my senior colleagues
to critique before
I sent it out.
It came back covered in red pen.
[INAUDIBLE] And I was just
thinking, what was I thinking?
I can't be a professor.
This is the most
ridiculous thing.
How did I ever think that
I could possibly do this?
But then I got a little
perspective on it.
I realized that this
professor had taken time
to not only read the paper
through and make comments,
but there were notes about
reading the background
literature on the paper.
This wasn't their field, so
they had read all the references
and thought about how I could
have improved the paper.
Who has time to do that?
The only person who
has time to do that
is someone who is completely
and totally dedicated
to my success.
So it was criticism.
It was criticism.
There was criticism!
[LAUGHTER]
But it was criticism that
was delivered because they
believed I could
do this, and wanted
to help me, put their money
where their mouth was,
spend time helping
me be successful.
So next time you get back
a draft covered with red,
don't think of it as
harsh, I can't do it,
blood of a massacre of
the paper spewing out.
You think about it as love.
[LAUGHTER]
Criticism takes time.
It's love!
Red love pouring out
all over the paper.
Criticism is
important, but the way
it's delivered-- if you
feel it's delivered in a way
that the person really
believes in you,
then it can really
motivate you to do better.
So criticism is good,
but how you deliver
it makes a huge difference.
All right.
So Mary O'Reilly who is a
graduate student here at MIT,
did all these really
cool little cartoons.
Little call out to Mary, now.
You're a student now, but
think about what you can do.
You don't have to sacrifice
completely for your science.
You can do art on the side.
So Mary had a hobby and
it's put to good use.
So which response
would you rather hear
if you did poorly on a test?
And I don't know if
you can see this.
This is a C-, which is not a
good score for someone who is
a high achiever.
Undeserved praise
can be super harmful.
"This is a good score for you.
You should be pleased."
What is this person
telling this person
by giving them that praise?
That's the best they can do.
You should be happy with a C-.
No.
No one should be
happy with a C-.
Of course, if it's pass,
no record, and you're
just shooting for that
pass-- but, no, no, no.
No one should be
happy with that.
All right.
So you have to be
careful about that.
The worst thing you can do is
send the message to someone
that they messed up, but that's
all that it can be expected
of you is to mess up.
Bad criticism.
We may have all received that.
Yeah, you'll have to try
harder if you want to pass.
No feedback can also
be harmful, because you
might have this idea that
you don't belong here.
And if no one's countering that
and telling you you do belong,
then you're just taking
that message away.
And wise criticism can be,
again, the most powerful thing.
Saying, hey, I know
you were doing really
well in recitation.
I'm not sure what
happened on the exam,
but let's sit together
and try to figure out.
You did this part really well.
You just need to figure out how
to demonstrate your knowledge
on this other part of the exam.
So just a brief story on this.
Some of my friends who
are professors, parents
call them up.
Do you know how much
tuition I'm paying?
Why did my kid not get an A?
I have never gotten
that phone call here,
partly because everybody knows
that MIT is a tough place,
and so, they don't send
their kid with the idea
that the money in tuition is
guaranteeing any kind of grade.
But I did get a phone
call from a parent once.
And they called
me and they said,
I just had to share
with you this story,
it's about my daughter
who's in your class.
They said, first
exam comes in MIT,
and she doesn't do that well.
And she calls me, and she's
crying, and she's crying a lot.
And she said, dad,
I really studied.
I'm telling you,
I thought I knew this material,
but this was my grade.
And I don't know what happened,
I really thought I knew it.
And she's like, can
you come and get me?
He's like, the first exam.
It's still September, right?
And so, he doesn't
know what to do,
and he says, well, I'm going
to come get you immediately.
Let's just see how you
feel in a little bit.
So then he gets a call
back a few hours later.
And you say, Dad!
Dad!
My TA emailed me!
They said, I know you
know the material better
than your grade on the test.
I told you, dad!
I told you that I knew
the material better.
And the TA knew I knew!
I knew I knew the
material better!
He said, you can
come in and talk
about test-taking strategies.
And so, the dad said, so I
don't need to come and get you?
She's like, no, I'm good.
Right?
So a little bit of the
message that that TA sent,
saying, I know that
you know this better.
Let's get together and
figure out what we can do.
It was everything
to this one person.
So wise criticism, very helpful.
He still said, yeah, that
wasn't a good performance, but I
you can do better.
OK.
So I just want to emphasize that
no feedback is not a solution.
Sometimes having these
conversations of criticism,
ugh.
So the easiest route
is say nothing.
But that is not a good route.
And let me just try to
convince you of that.
In doing so, we have some
more cool Mary cartoons.
And we're just going to leave
the classroom for a minute.
In this scenario,
we have a professor
coming in, yelling
at this male student,
and saying nothing to
this female student who
is sitting right next to him.
So the professor comes
in, said, you should
have had this done yesterday!
I'm giving a talk
next week in Texas,
and I need to have
these PowerPoint slides!
Why haven't you finished
this experiment?
I have to get going!
And then he leaves the lab.
And so, in the little blurb
here from the female students
thoughts he can't
hear, she said,
I wish she cared as
much about my project.
It's just not fair.
And then the man is
thinking, he never
yells at the girls like
that, and her project
isn't going any
better than mine.
It's just not fair.
So the woman is upset about
not getting yelled at,
which sort of seems
counterintuitive at first,
until you realize
that the one graduate
student's getting
yelled at because he
wants his data for a talk.
So he's never asking the
female student for her data
for a talk.
He's never really talking to
her at all about her research.
It's not going well, and
he doesn't even care.
She is apparently so
insignificant to him.
She's too insignificant, her
research is so unimportant,
he doesn't even have
time to yell at her.
He's not interest
in yelling at her
because he's not going to use
her research for anything.
He has no expectations that she
would ever deliver something
that would be talk worthy.
That's at least
what's in her mind.
Meanwhile, the male professor's
very proud of himself
for never yelling at the girls.
And the male students are really
angry that the girls don't
get yelled at, not
realizing that he's
paying some attention.
He actually cares if
they're getting results.
So this is a lose-lose
situation for everybody.
So along these lines I was
called on to, at one point,
interview all of the
female graduate students
in the chemistry department,
and all the male students
in the chemistry
department, to figure out
how they figured out
whether they would
apply for academic positions.
And I was given this task
because the department was
very low on the list of the
number of female graduate
students who were applying
for faculty positions.
So they wanted to figure out
why the women weren't applying.
And who better to figure
that out than me, a woman.
All right.
So I actually was
kind of curious
to see what people would say.
So again, this is not
statistically significant.
I've collected some
data over the years that
is statistically significant.
This was just
conversations that I had,
but I just wanted to
share this with you.
So I asked both
men and women, how
do you know if you're good
enough to be a professor?
And both said, I don't know.
It was the same.
It was the same answer.
They both said, I don't know.
And it's like, well,
what do you do with that?
And the women said, well, I wait
for the professor to tell me
that I'm good enough.
And if they don't tell
me, I assume I'm not.
The men said, well,
I go ahead and apply,
and if I'm not good
enough, the professor
is likely to tell me
that at some point.
So meanwhile, the
professor is saying nothing
to either group about
whether they're good enough.
The women are taking that
as a message they're not.
The men are saying,
I'm just going
to go ahead and try
until someone stops me.
So no feedback, you
might be sending
messages you don't intend.
I don't think these
professors were intending
to send message to
the female students
that they weren't good enough.
They just were busy doing
stuff and didn't say anything
to anyone.
So it's a reminder to
give feedback to people.
Because if there's
no feedback, you
don't know what the individual
is taking away from that.
In the absence of
it, own insecurities
will often come into play.
All right.
So other things that one can
do is change the narrative.
Because, remember,
as I was just saying,
people have their own
insecurities going.
And so, sometimes
you want to let
them know that perhaps other
people have had insecurities
as well, and that it's OK,
and that failing sometimes
is not only OK, it's
part of the process.
So for high achievers, it's
important to reassure them
that everyone has had difficulty
at some point in their career.
So this serves as a
counter narrative,
this story they're telling
themselves, that somehow you
have to be perfect
all the time to really
be successful in science.
You don't have to be, but we
need to share those stories.
The CV, it's a
list of successes.
It's a list of papers.
It's a list of awards.
It doesn't say on there, this is
what I've done with my career.
No.
What you've done
with your career,
between every success
are a ton of failures.
But we don't list the
things that don't work,
we just list the
things that do work.
Our publications are full of
the experiments that work,
not the experiments
that didn't work.
So it's really easy
for people to look
at someone who's
successful and think,
they've never had to struggle.
It's been super easy for them.
They've never failed.
And that is just not the case.
So if we share those
stories with the students,
it can help them realize that
maybe this bad grade isn't
the end of the world.
It's all OK.
It's part of the process.
All right.
So this is the last exercise.
So recall a moment where a
mentor shared a story with you
about a time when he or she
struggled with a concept
or felt inadequate,
but then reached
a high level of
achievement, or you
could recall your own story.
So something that
someone shared with you
that made a difference, or
perhaps something that you
could tell your students
this semester if they're
all of a sudden going, how
did I get into this place?
I'm not sure that I belong here.
What could you
share with them that
would help them move forward?
All right.
Find your partners.
Think about a time.
AUDIENCE: I think
for a time when--
at least a story that
was a counter-narrative
for me was thinking about
my own struggles in my PhD
where there was a long
string of failures
where it felt like
nothing was working
and I wasn't really
getting anywhere.
And it was really hard
to see the finish line,
and it got me really down.
It felt very difficult. I wasn't
as happy as I could have been.
And I think what really
helped me break out
of that was hearing
from my own advisor
that she had had a pretty
long and arduous PhD as well.
There was a lot of struggle.
And that those failures came
in the exact same way, where
they're stacking on
top of each other.
And it just feels like there
is no end really in sight,
and maybe that you're not
even good enough for this.
But seeing how far she made
it, and how much she succeeded
after that really, really
reassured me, and makes me
feel better about
the whole thing.
It makes you realize
everything's going to be OK.
This is not atypical.
It doesn't say something
about me, personally.
Really what's
reassuring is that it
feels like everything
is really going
to work out at the end of it.
And that changed my entire
attitude really about my PhD.
I feel tremendously better
about everything since then.
AUDIENCE: That's very inspiring.
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, for me, I felt
it a lot during undergrad,
and I still feel it
somewhat in grad school,
but one experience was
even having an opportunity
to participate in a
summer program at MIT.
So I went to a
community college,
and my parents couldn't
afford to send me
to a top-tier university.
We didn't have money saved
up for me to go to one,
and so the advice was to
go to community college
first, establish your GPA,
get some scholarships,
and then transfer to
a four-year institute.
And while I was at
that community college,
I didn't feel like I would have
any major opportunities to go
and do research, especially
at an institute like MIT.
And I came across the
application for the MIT summer
research program
through another program
that I was involved in
at my community college.
And I was like, OK,
I'll just apply to it.
They'll probably not
accept me or even
consider my application,
but I'll still do it.
And I did it.
I applied.
And I ended up getting
into the program.
And that one opportunity really
opened a lot of doors for me,
and now I'm able to be
a graduate student here.
So, yeah, that was a moment
where I really felt insecure,
and the whole imposter
syndrome really affected me.
But I'm happy that I
took that opportunity.
Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's
a really awesome story.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
when I started college,
I got a really, really bad
grade on one of my tests.
I think it was actually my
second semester of college.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: I called my dad.
And it was the first
bad test I've ever
had in my entire life.
I was so upset.
I called my dad and I said,
dad, dad, I'm so sorry!
I'm failing!
And I had a full-ride
scholarship,
so I thought I was going to lose
my scholarship because of one
bad test.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
understand that.
AUDIENCE: And my dad
said, no, no, it's OK.
It's totally fine.
When I was in college--
the same exact college--
I failed miserably my first
test in this math class.
And I just worked
really hard and studied,
and tried to talk
to people, and made
sure that I knew exactly
what I was doing.
And by the end of the
semester, my teacher was like,
don't even come in for
the final because you're
going to break the curve.
So you can do it.
One bad test is
not the end of you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's cool.
I wish my--
AUDIENCE: It really helps.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I can imagine
that would really help.
Yeah.
So I guess, growing up, I
didn't have female scientists--
I don't know.
The media doesn't really portray
female scientists, slash,
I didn't know anyone that had
a PhD or anything like that.
So when I got to college,
I knew I was always
interested in science,
but I didn't actually
know what that meant.
And so, I was
really lucky enough
to have a wonderful
mentor in undergrad.
And she, was the department
head of chemistry,
so that was really awesome.
But we got really close,
and she would tell me
about her journey
as a scientist,
and how she started out
becoming a lecturer,
and raising a family, and
being a woman in science,
and what that meant for
people's perception,
and how she felt like
she never really got
the respect that she deserved.
And she would always make
sure that we referred to her
as doctor, because it
was the fact that she
had worked so hard for it, and
had not been taken seriously.
So she shared a
lot of like how she
didn't feel like
she got the respect
or deserved to almost be
in this position of power.
But she was an extremely
successful scientist,
and did wonderful things, and
was department head of our
at our school.
And just really
showed me that even
if you don't feel
like you can do it,
or you're not
getting the respect,
you can still be
really successful.
And having those conversations
and just hearing her story,
made me feel like,
OK, I can do this,
and allowed me to address
like my insecurities.
And her support where she felt
like I could go to grad school,
was a main reason why I felt
like I could actually do it.
Because she talked about,
it wasn't in her plans,
but she still like
went through it.
And, like, look,
I'm a Professor now,
even though I don't necessarily
feel like I should have been,
or could have at times.
And so, that was
really awesome to hear
and really made me feel like
grad school was an option
before I even got here.
And before, I didn't even
think about grad school.
AUDIENCE: That's great.
I'm so glad that she was
able to bring you here.
AUDIENCE: She's wonderful.
AUDIENCE: I think a good
example, in my case is my mom.
So obviously, her experience
is 30 years ago and in Korea,
so it might be not that
reflective of how things are
done in the States right now.
But basically, it was a lot
harder for her, as a woman,
to get a job than her
male counterparts,
because people were
worried that she might quit
when she gets married,
when she gets pregnant,
when she has a baby.
And even after she
got a baby and she
has continued working
in her workplace,
she was continuously
judged by other people.
Because when she
worked hard, people
were blaming her for not putting
in that much of a dedication
to her home.
But if she was not
working hard enough,
people were like, why are you
like not working hard enough?
And you should not pay
too much of attention
to your kids and your family.
AUDIENCE: You can't win.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
So she had to put in a
lot more time and effort
into both her household
and in her workplace
to fight with the
negative stereotype,
and not to get blame.
So yeah, her story
really touched me,
and just keeping me aware that
those kinds of stereotypes
are going out there, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think the one
mentor that's really stuck out
or has had a big impact on
me, especially in grad school,
has been my advisor.
Especially when I came
to MIT, I definitely
had a stereotype of what an
MIT grad student should be.
And it was like,
they should only
be focused on their academics.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I had a
lot of personal things
I was struggling
with that I thought
I had to leave behind me when I
would come into the workplace.
And it almost became this
really overbearing burden
of, I had to keep this
personal side of me a secret
and I could only have this
academic side of me in public.
So having a mentor who is very
open about her own struggles,
and who's willing to share
more about her personal life,
made me feel more comfortable
bringing my full self
to the table when I am in lab.
So that's definitely
had a big impact on me.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I feel that the
media is gradually
changing from showing the
typical nerdy scientist
into showing that,
hey, scientists also
have personal lives.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That they are people.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
really like that.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Cool, cool.
CATHY L. DRENNAN:
So I'll just briefly
tell you one story
for me, which,
if you don't feel comfortable
sharing with your students,
you can share my stories.
That's fine.
I have a long list.
So one thing that you can tell
people which sometimes helps
is that professor
Drennan is dyslexic.
So I was diagnosed
in first grade.
I was a very smart
and articulate kid,
and I liked talking to adults.
And so, they assumed
I was sort of smart,
but then I couldn't
learn to read.
So I was in the upper group, and
then the somewhat lower group,
and lower group, and the lowest
group, and the remedial group.
And it took me to sixth grade
until I learned how to read--
second time through sixth grade.
I had to do that twice.
And so, I was told I would
never be able to graduate
from high school.
And so, when I graduated
from high school, then
I went to college.
And then I was like, ha, ha!
Look at me!
And then I went to grad
school and then I kept going.
It's like, oh!
Faculty position at MIT!
Let's go!
And I just needed to prove
that I could do these things,
but it was hard.
And there are many really
embarrassing dyslexic mistakes
that I have made
over the years too.
And when I first
started here, I was
very nervous about anybody
knowing that I was dyslexic,
and I have gotten beyond that.
So I've now been
videotaped by a whole bunch
of the dyslexic
associations, and done
all sorts of different things
where I share my stories.
So if you don't want to share a
story about something from you,
you can share my stories,
even if they're my students.
I am cool with everybody
knowing that I am dyslexic.
And if you're my TA, and
I write words that are not
words on the board, or
switch numbers around,
just say, "Professor
Drennan, other way,"
or something like that.
That's cool.
So feel free to
share these stories.
And I think it's so important
that students know there's
more than one path to success.
And that not
everyone is the same,
and people may struggle
with different things.
They may have different
insecurities, but it's all OK.
And those struggles
often make us who we are,
and that science doesn't work
perfectly the first time.
We have to get in there and
just keep working at it.
And the struggles we
face in our own life
is often just a really
good motivating factor
for doing some really
great research.
All right.
So again, you're very
welcome to share my stories.
I have extra ones, if
you want to hear times
that I felt insecure.
But I heard a lot of
discussion, so maybe people
feel like they are willing to
share a story with us right
now?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Going off what we
were discussing about how
in science, so much of what
we hear, or what's told to us,
is all successes.
And also knowing that a lot of
those failures, at least for me
personally, they kind
of come in waves.
There's not just one
failure at a time.
It's a lot.
[SOFT LAUGHTER]
And it really wore on me at the
time, but what I think really
helped me was my own mentor
telling me that she struggled
through her PhD.
It took a long time.
It was a slog.
It just reminded me
that it's not always
a straight line to
get to the finish.
And more importantly, it's
that things will get better.
It'll all work out.
Everything's going to be OK.
And I think that really helped
me continuing on to my PhD.
CATHY L. DRENNAN: Yeah.
Yeah, that's wonderful.
Yeah.
And I often think of the waves.
And it's like things are
going really, really well,
and then it slows down, and
then things are not working.
And if the amplitude was up
and down and this, it's like,
I'll be OK.
But often it's up and then down,
and then down, and then down,
and then down, and then down.
And you're like, in other
people their amplitudes are
different in the lab.
And it's like, that
person has stuff working.
This person has stuff working.
What is wrong?
But the thing is
that over time, it's
like when it's down like
this, then when it goes up,
it stays up longer also.
So it's like getting
you there again.
So yeah, that's why these
stories can be pretty powerful.
Anybody else have one
they want to share?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think why
it's been difficult for me
during grad school,
especially in the beginning,
was that I was dealing with
some personal struggles
from before grad
school and during.
And I kind of felt
like I had this burden
of keeping it a secret, because
I didn't want to come off
as overly emotional.
Or that because I was dealing
with these personal struggles,
that I wasn't taking
my sciences seriously.
So having a mentor
that opened up
about how she had also
had personal struggles
and how she still was
able to be successful,
was really meaningful
to me, to feel
like I could be both a
person and a scientist.
CATHY L. DRENNAN: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
It is one package, right?
Yeah.
We're all a package
of these things.
So yeah, that's wonderful.
And I think that sometimes
it just looks to people
as if everything
is going so well,
and they just don't see
the inside struggles.
And you don't really
know, necessarily,
what else is going on.
And so, when you're comfortable
sharing these things,
it can be so powerful.
And I feel like sometimes when
people are getting through it,
it's like, now you have to
be a professor because you've
got to share these
stories with other people.
And that figuring out how to
deal with the struggle, I mean,
that's what it's about.
It's not about doing everything
perfectly the first time.
It's how to deal with
failure, get yourself
up, get through those times.
And that's what gives you
the strength to really go
after doing hard stuff.
All right.
Are there any other ones?
OK.
All right.
Let's move on.
The bad news.
We all have stereotypes.
I think all of you are
sitting there thinking,
man, let me just count all the
different stereotypes I have.
We all have stereotypes.
We all have unconscious bias.
Now, maybe some of you will
be like, oh, wait a minute.
Why did I react that way?
Oh, man!
There's another
stereotype I have.
We all can be victims of
stereotype threats or imposter
syndrome.
Stereotype threat can
be pretty harmful.
It can lead to
underperformance and a feeling
of being judged unfairly.
But there's good news.
You create an environment
of trust in your classroom
or in your lab,
give wise criticism,
and that can really mediate the
negative effects of stereotype.
If you're part of a
team doing something,
if someone believes that someone
else believes in them-- they're
not sure they can do it,
but my team believes in me,
therefore, I can't do
it, because my team
is pretty smart.
These are all ways--
and we have to help everyone
reach their full potential.
The students you'll be
working with this semester
are crazy, smart,
and cool people.
And some of them
may be insecure,
and you can really help them
get to their full potential.
And it's an amazing opportunity
to teach smart people.
So I hope you have
a wonderful time,
and I hope that those horses
that are dressed like zebras
in your classroom are
feeling very zebra-ish
by the end of the semester.
So thank you very much
for your attention.
I loved the stories
you're shared today,
and have a wonderful semester.
[APPLAUSE]